welcome to this video coverage for
around eight of the gushy move memoria
and this around I'm going for the game
Omidyar off Nakamura is the game of the
day just like I did with the same
pairing in round three I was arguing a
bit with myself should i do another game
yum ok let's go through the two other
games quickly on mentioned them there
was the game cards and playing wide
against kayaking but cousin played a
very harmless opening in a way and
didn't get anywhere near even the
slightest initiative so this game ended
in a draw without them pretty much
anything happening on the other hand the
game kawana raja baath was interesting
we got a complicated Kings Indian and
corona adds some pressure along the way
pretty much the whole game it seemed
like white had little something at least
in my eye and still raja baath probably
didn't really need to lose this game but
at the end he did he allowed corona
support too much activity and at the end
karana won the game so raja baath has
some lost the first game in this event
going down to fifty percent or corona
with the win is now one plus one having
some chances to to catch Marcus Carson
ok so let's go for mamedyarov against
nakamura to fighting players and let's
see what they have played yeah a sloth
um the camera is I'm going for that
regularly it seems in this tournament
mamedyarov is playing a number of lines
again
slav quite a variety of choices yes
played this recently queen bee three g3
III I mean all moves that are somewhat
legal he has tried I'm a bit surprised
actually that he is not playing queen
bee three more he had lost somewhat
painful game against Vichy honored in
the candidates but other than that he
had excellent results with this move so
I'm a bit surprised that he's not going
for their TM okay he's playing g3 year
against Nakamura moves that she has
played before of course this move is in
fact gaining somewhat in popularity
which is not so much because it's so
great it's just a testament in a way of
the solidity of blacks defenses in the
Slav the mainline million main lines are
pretty much um yeah okay for black and
people try to get fresh positions
quickly if possible um after g3 black
can take on c4 it's not bad very often
the resulting positions are very much
like in the catalog or can easily
transpose for example after Bishop g2
black can't play b5 and andy sixx to go
to a catalan gambit style risky for
black though um yeah black has a number
of options eme the camera is playing
Bishop f5 which is certainly a normal
reaction or solid reaction I wouldn't
really recommend to take the point i
think it's not especially from
psychological point of view not a great
choice to take and grab it um however
instead of Bishop f5 there is also the
move Bishop GE form and if you ask me
what is
recommendation for black players it is
this move Bishop g4 in fact I'm
producing a series on openings for the
internet chess club the SSC we're also
do is laugh defense repertoire and
they're also went for Bishop g4 the
reason why I went for Bishop g4 is
amongst others the line that is played
in the game it is not terrible for black
I'm not saying that but I just in
comparison I just think that Bishop g4
is the more somewhat easier option in a
win 93 e6 and now night each form all
this is in a way related the ideas at
least to the slow Slav and so-called so
slow Slav which is starting with this
fifth compare this this is a well-known
line that is believed to be very very
very very slightly better for why
because of the bishop pair that well
white will gain black however is
exceptionally solid here and if you
compare this to the game yeah it's quite
similar but why does the pony too but
it's played g3 by g3 has some sort of
semi useful move it's however quite nice
that this Bishop is still on an open
diagonal and sometimes white even is
able to play f3e for in one move so this
is this feels a bit like an improved
version of this snow Slav um another
idea for Wyatt here's the move queen bee
three that I didn't like so much for
black um if black response queen bee six
quite normal looking why it has this
idea and and don't really like the
endgame positions here much the problem
is that quite often I can avoid this end
game by going to mean a six which
obviously due to
form is not advisable him so queen bee
three is in fact a good alternative for
white ok this was played Bishop before
very often black it's provoking the move
f3 which to be honest I'm not sure about
because white just have a look at this
white very quickly how black does not
want to trade if black trades here the
problem is that there is a quick before
b5 coming and this is also not stoppable
by a six and there's still this coming
with a very nice initiative for white so
black retreats and now there's a four
and well black has provoked all that f3
was a was provoked and why does making a
good use out of that to be honest isn't
this a good position for white I think
that the space advantage and the two
bishops I mean they should count for
something it obviously is a position
that i like because well I'm a fan of
the bishop path as most players and also
like space a lot so I am certainly at
least from from superficial point if you
would prefer white him now camera played
Bishop e7 here which seems to be
technically a novel team um black had to
try to the capture before after which
Bishop f4 Queen c 8f e-form led to quite
a nice position for white it's just a
good Center black has some counter play
of course he can play nine h5 for
example after which the bishop cannot
easily retreat youtube this trick here
so it's not like black is lost but it
feels like the whole approach that
macabre went for here is very
provocative okay he played Bishop e7
after which
I with the RF play Bishop f4 gaining
this tempo certainly making sense Quincy
8 but what I don't like is the next move
here that is playing me Gareth went for
the caption did it so rather quickly and
I really don't think that this fits into
into the whole the whole strategic
outline of this position white is
enjoying a very useful space advantage
and I'm not sure why I should trade the
e pawn against the C porn here even
allowing black some development of the
knight to c6 I thought that a simple
move like Bishop g2 or maybe long
castles which is not so clear to me but
okay no castles s 9 h 5 i'm sorry but
let's say just Bishop g2 this has an
additional benefit of covering the h1
rook so that after move like night h5 I
can actually simply retreat and there is
not night XD 3-5 is in fact quite quite
useless here well if this isn't this a
good position for wide I don't know
black of course has some play it's not
like he sees busted can play 97 maybe b6
and okay it's a game but just in
comparison to compare it to the game I
think white has just better chances some
look look look look at this eat XD 595
of course black is somewhat cramped he
wants to exchange a pair of knights
night XD 5c txt five so white has traded
a pair of nights which should help like
because he's got less space traits
helped him and Black now has gained the
square c64 his night so it just feels
like um yeah a good trade to me for
black
not quite sure why mamady our offer went
for that it's not likely that he white
is not worse but just felt like the
other continuations us just put more
pressure on black okay he canceled long
now and knight c6 was played yeah here
of course you notice that the queen is
just opposite term whites King um black
could have considered to play b6 but
note that he is not really well
developed and white can simply answer
that with King be one just one possible
answer but a good one it turns out that
black here is not faring so well after
that black takes him this is check and
here black icing and terrible shape
suffering from all those all those pins
that's winning from white it's not just
uncomfortable b6 is maybe not very well
time so 96 seems fine why not develop a
piece king be one getting out of the sea
foam yeah now here and I camera opts for
a very interesting setup the thing is as
mentioned this I think somewhat help
like that he got is Knight to c6 but
still there is the one very important
question what about the King on yet you
could just castle short it's not not
totally totally crazy but it would give
white a ready-made plan h4 h5 opening up
the H file or at least gaining space
some on the side of the board where the
king is located so not clear that short
castle is such a great idea I think
Nakamura's approach is very interesting
he played g5 gaining a tempo on the
bishop it retweet it and then f5 first
it looks a bit weakening but I think
it's a rather good idea it gains space
on the kingside useful it
has a good spot on f6 for the bishop and
the King can go to f7 covering the six
pawn these six looks a bit like weakness
on half opened file but yeah how is
white actually going to pressurize the
spawn it's not evident how this is how
this should happen quickly so an
interesting approach I like it yeah
Mammadyarov tried to open up stuff with
g4 of course black must keep it as close
as possible around the king bishop f2
and king f7 as mentioned this King moved
to protect the six porn so very
complicated and and double-edged
position it seems that the next move by
mohmmad yarrow firm is a mistake he
played a rookie one which looks
perfectly logical on the half-open foul
but it has a serious serious problem
this move black is intending here to
play b6 now opening up the B file
against the king and it seems that white
should play prophylactic move against
that and this is Bishop b5 I think this
is helpful because b6 now is not good
due to Queen a4 just attacking the night
and it frankly does not have any good
square yeah black can not easily go
forward this move is just terribly
annoying with c6 coming so probably this
must be played and while this is not
much of a difference why does just an
excellent shape this was probably the
right move preventing v6 after rook e1
Nakamura was going for b6 and this is
now quickly turning the table to blacks
favor I mean turning the table is
probably somewhat m precise expression
because white was not better before but
black after b6 is definitely
it's just like white has noah
compensation form this line opening up
very difficult to play now if for
example why takes on b6 there is the
booth will be 8 and quickly blackest
piling up on the B file so just a book
battles to take if after be six white is
playing Bishop b5 there is just just the
capture this might end in fact i
transposed to the game on something
similar than the game yeah the response
i think is the relatively best one
Mammadyarov response i mean queen a4
after b.tech see you played Bishop a6
attacking the Queen and this at least
sets them the most the most difficult
problems to solve for black Bishop a6
Queen c7 and now Bishop b5 coming back
yeah if Y just takes here playing a
normal move there is rook b8 and the
bishop f6 and this is just a very strong
attack note that after Bishop b5 there
is Queen B 7 and white will resign
immediately at least that's very likely
to happen as you lose the bishop for no
compensation whatsoever so this is what
mamedyarov tried Bishop b5 yeah here in
this position um my camera played rugby
aid which is not bad it seems but it
it's also possible that here we had a
better continuation there is no real
reason why black shouldn't take on
deform after this I think black is just
better I'm not sure what
White's big point is I mean Bishop d7
attacking him you can cover from age six
and it's not clear that white is any
compensation I mean it's two pawns right
Black's got seven points against five of
course it's a bit of a bit of a murky
structure but still black is certainly
better here night ext4 was a very
serious alternative this is what
nakamura played also an attractive move
of course getting the rook on the
half-open half-open nabi file yeah but
it allows us something that I know I
probably would have liked to prevent if
white takes now we need to check this
black has the strongest look before and
he will regain the bishop like that for
example and then at the end Black has
this this great advantage with the open
up and be firm yeah mommy job in fact
has a very spectacular Mafia and instead
he played he took on e6 white think
white quite a move after that black
needs to be precise and I don't think
that Nakamura played the best
continuation here he he just took the
rook but it feels like rook takes b5 was
somewhat stronger just immediately
liquidating this attacking piece the
best continuation seems to be chatty
okie 797 25 and now see form and that's
a very very important to the c-4 move
just shuts the position down the bishop
1 F 2 especially is a problem please now
white cannot activate this piece easily
can try something like that but just
this just takes ages in the meantime
black has ideas like rupee eight and
play on the beef oh so this should be
quite substantially better for black
instead knock on where i took the rook
of course it's three the obvious move
but after that it seems that white has
at least some practical compensation and
this Bishop is attacking the d5 pawn
there is rookie one with a check
possibly coming so all this is not clear
at all it seems that the computer at
least prefers black still but it's a
getting much more much more unclear in a
way that's trickier to play yeah
Nakamura played Rock the eighth which
seems like the best move and here mayara
captured on c5 getting a porn back and
also opening up the default square which
can be useful for a bishop of the right
moment even for a queen so it's all it's
all very very tough to play Bishop f6
looks like a good move controlling
dimension D foursquare and immediately
threatening on be tube this was the idea
all along with the bishop to have six
look to be 80 k bishop deform the only
only response really and here king of
seven Osprey this is showing that
Nakamura is going for a win he also
could have taken him and taken on c6
which it first looks a bit scary after
Queen takes g7 but it seems that Queen
take C 5 rupee won't check check King b6
is really just the draw I mean white can
draw with the stuff like that check but
there is not more than that however
Nakamura already was some I think beyond
the point where he wanted to draw he
just dropped back to have seven and
tries to play this position for win yeah
and after rook d1 which seems to be less
precise he really got a substantial
advantage instead of rook to e1
there was this capture and then each
form maybe this was relatively best
chance the whole thing is really not
that clear because this bishop on g6
it's not easily yeah easily kicked away
from c6 it's always attacking d5 with a
check so it's not so easy for black to
improve here also the seaborne can can
play an important role quickly if you
just consider if like we need 5 for
example threatening medium white can
block this and then maybe use the C porn
this isn't totally clear it's probably
better for black but it just puts up
some stiff resistance in the game he
played a rookie one as mentioned and
this does not really help much you
really need the edge porn 2202 to get to
fight blacks um King position better
yeah king of 8 getting out of a possible
capture on d5 was check right played a 3
creating some some looked for the king
now he could have taken for example but
after this there is no real great
continuation yeah something like Bishop
g5 there is just Queenie 5 threatening
mate mmm and threatening the bishop
which just wins outright yeah this is
what was played and now nakamura
exchanged here and went to e5 and around
here it's it's very tough to still
suggest any serious improvements for
white the problem is the lack of
coordination this rook cannot easily
move without allowing a made on b2 and
all pieces are somewhat tied together on
the white side
like of course also has a material
advantage with the exchange but it's
really a bit of the matter of a
coordination here Dwight is not
coordinated really well rock d to check
yeah before yeah not too happy with the
king is not amused but what else was
down this was just hanging with am a
don't be too and there was no really no
real alternative yeah I move like Quincy
to you can play and if you exchange
greens you might as well resign
especially considering that this is
winning the Seaborn so before was played
and now the camera just takes everything
here on a three the first porn and the
second one yeah why does just trying to
muddy the waters but there is no
compensation for the lost exchange yeah
King is secured on a jade and shortly
afterwards can't let go some able to use
the f-bomb yeah I'm a jar of continued
for a while but the end the f porn is
just just too strong and there is also a
deep bond yeah that's a strong tactical
move white can take the rook but can you
two will win the house always check
that's very important something like
check check and then f1 with a maid to
come
yeah white planted Bishop c4 but yeah
he's far beyond beyond saving c7 is also
lost him the after rook takes you four
black being a pawn up yeah this is just
too much so mahmoud yehia resigned yeah
he's really having this kind of roller
coaster games all the time it's it's
it's very it seems very tough for him to
just play a somewhat conservative game
in a way always this kind of this kind
of hand-to-hand combat games in fact I
think that right out of the opening
around here white certainly had a good
position I mean but this is already
trade I think really really helped knock
him right in a way to set up his pieces
and after that I think he had a very
satisfactory position of course they
have been yeah some inaccurate moves by
both sides which is to expect it and
such a complicated battle but at the end
i think nakamura really did a good job
here fighting fighting for the window
all the time just trying to keep the
position sharp and unbalanced so he was
um yeah he's bounced back immediately
from the after the loss against them
Carson in the round before so um yeah I
hope you enjoyed the coverage here I'll
be back tomorrow with the round nine and
I'm just thinking what is the next game
that cowls and has its kawana right very
important game of course after kawana
has won today so we will see a calzon
playing a white against Caruana very a
very interesting game certainly he wants
to have some revenge for this somewhat
painful loss from the
first turn okay i hope you enjoyed it as
mentioned i'll be back tomorrow thanks
for watching